شكرا للزميل نايف المشاهد التي كنا نراها
يعني تدمي القلوب وتكسر الوجدان بعد نحو
خمسه ايام على هذا الزلزال خمسه ايام
اعزائي المشاهدين مرت على الزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا خمسه ايام تتضاءل
معها فرص العثور على ناجين تحت الانقاب هي
خمسه ايام رفعت عدد الضحايا في تركيا الى
1891 قتيلا فيما تجاوز عدد الجرحى 75 الف
مصاب
ومن نجا من الزلزال ضربه التشرد حيث تم
اجلاء اكثر من خمسه وسبعين الفا من
المناطق المنكوبه في اكبر كارثه زلزال
شهدتها المنطقه عبر التاريخ
اما في سوريا فالزلزال الذي طال خمسه
محافظات اوذى بحياه اربعه الاف شخص حتى
الان
في حين توقع المرصد السوري ان يتجاوز عدد
القتل هذا الرقم
وتشير المعلومات القادمه من هناك ان
المستشفيات تغص بالجثث فيما يسابق عمال
الاغاثه الوقت للعثور على احياء تحت
الانقاض
[موسيقى]
لا تخاف تمام
يلا يلا
[موسيقى]
طالعين
هيئه اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه
اعلنت انه تم اجلاء اكثر من 28 الف شخص من
المناطق المنكوبه بالزلزال منهم اكثر من
اربعه الاف عن طريق البر والسكك الحديديه
واكثر من اربعه وعشرين الفا عن طريق الجو
وبحسب الهيئه سيتم وضع الاشخاص الذين تم
اجلائهم في مناطق الاقامه التي حددتها
مكاتب الولايات واداره الكوارث والطوارئ
والتركيه
بعد خمسه ايام على وقوع الزلزال فرص
العثور على ناجين اصبحت مهمه مستحيله ولكن
اراده الحياه اقوى شاب تركي نجا من الموت
بعد 94 94 ساعه نتابع القصه
كبطل خرج مبتسما من تحت الركام فريق
الانقاذ رفع له تحيه الحياه بعد ان بقي
محاصرا 94 ساعه تحت الركام في غاز عنتاب
التركيه بالقرب من مركز الزلزال
عمليه انقاذ عدنان كركوت الذي يبلغ من
العمر 17 عاما كانت اشبهه بالمعجزه بعد ان
اصبحت عمليه البحث عن ناجين اشبه
بالمستحيل من حسن حظ عدنان ان والدته كانت
بانتظاره على عكس الاخرين ضمته الى صدرها
وبكى الاثنان فرحا بالعوده الى الحياه
ابتسامه عدنان لم تخفي الدموع في عينيه
وايمانه بالنجاه ساعده على البقاء على قيد
الحياه كما وصف ايامه الاربعه تحت الركام
قلب الام لم يتسع فرحا بعوده فلذه كبدها
[موسيقى]
فخرجت من نافذه سياره الاسعاف لترحب
بالحياه من جديد محاسن حداره العربيه
[موسيقى]
على كل لمزيد من المتابعه في هذه التغطيه
ينضم الي من المنطقه الواقعه بين انطاقها
والريحانيه الصحفي مصطفى النعيمي استاذ
مصطفى اهلا وسهلا بك يعني لو تجسدت
الفاجعه بشكل من الاشكال يوما لكان اسمها
هذا الزلزال مع ذلك اسالك ان تنقل لنا
الصوره من الريحانيه وابرز مشاهداتك خصوصا
اذا كان هنالك عمليات
وصول للمساعدات عمليات الاغاثه عمليات
الانقاذ ساترك لك الكلمه
تحياتي لك استاذي الكريم والساده
المشاهدين الكرام نعم كما تشاهد هنا خلفي
هذا هذا الطريق المؤدي الى جسر الحديد
بمنتصف الطريق اتجاه انطاكيا الان يظهر
الدمار الهائل الذي حصل في الطريق الدولي
كما تشاهد الان في الكاميرا
اغير الكاميرا على الطرف الاخر كي تشاهد
مشهد بشكل اوسع كما تشاهد هذا الطريق
الدولي هناك في بدايه الطريق هنا الانحدار
الذي حصل والان تشاهد طبقات التربه كما
تشاهد الان طبقات التربه كيف حصل هذا
الانهيار في الطريق الدولي هنا على يميني
ايضا سياره
انقلبت في الطريق اثناء حدوث الزلزال كما
تشاهد الان هذه السياره لا ادري ان كان
بها احد او لا
ليس لدي معلومات كما تشاهد ما زال في
مكانها
وهذا عن قرب ان تعاني التربه تلاحظ بشكل
واضح حجم الانهيار الكبير الذي حصل في
الطريق وهذا امامي هذا تحت يعني انا امشي
على الطريق الان مائل جدا لا يمكن المشي
عليه كما تلاحظ في الصوره تماما
الصوره هي اوضح من ان اوصف المشهد كما
تشاهد الفرق ما بين الشارع هنا والطريق
الذي انهار بالطرف الاخر وهو وكانه صدع في
هذه المنطقه بالزداد ادى الى انقسام
الشارع من النصف منتصف تماما المسافه التي
اتحرك فيها الان كما تشاهد في الصوره
تقارب الكيلومتر والنصف الضمائر من
الطرفين الطرف هذا الذي هو المتضرر اكثر
لكن الطرف الثاني ايضا يعمل على اعاده
تاهيله من قبل الفرق المختصه بصيانه تلك
الطرق كما تشاهد الان هذا هو بعد ان قاموا
بتحريك الطبقه العليا من الاسفلت هذه
امامي كما تشاهد عباره مكونه من الركام
على الطرف الاخر هنا
مصطفى بس هل الطريق وفق متابعتك ومشاهداتك
صالحه يعني سالكه يمكن لاي قوافل اغاثه او
لفرق الانقاذ ان تستخدم هذا الطريق ام لا
المرور على هذا الطريق خطر
خطر جدا حتى اللحظه كما تشاهد الان ليس ما
اصل الى مكان افضل للوضوح لتوضيح المساله
هنا يقومون باعاده تاهيل الطريق ايضا كما
تشاهد الان هذه هنا اعمال الصيانه ما زالت
مستمره على الطرف الاخر لكنه بعيد قليل
الشيء ربما مسافه تفصلني عن هذا الطريق
قرابه 700 متر
المركبات موجوده في الطرف الاخر بمسافات
ربما قد تتجاوز ثلاثه كيلو مترات ذهابا
وايابا بسبب انه الطريق صغير جدا والسرعه
من المحتمل ان يتحرك فيها هؤلاء
المتواجدون لا اتوقع انها تتجاوز السرعه
عشره كيلو مترات في هذه في هذه المنطقه
بالذات التي اتواجد فيها عند جسر الحديد
الطريق الواصل ما بين كل من مدينه انطاكيا
ومدينه الريحانيه حدث هذا الانهيار في
داخل التربه كما تشاهد يعني الان واضح جدا
هذا الفرق الفرق الهائل ما بين الطريق
السابق والطريق الان الذي يقوموا بالعمل
عليه لكن السبب الرئيسي يعود الى الانحدار
هذا الذي موجود في منتصف الطريق كما تشاهد
هذا الاصل كان مرتفع عن الطريق الاسفلتي
على يميني بمسافه تقدر من 30 الى 35 سم
بينما الان هو منهار بمعدل متر الى الداخل
تم ابتلاعه بالكامل ودفعه الى الداخل
واعاده الطريق كما هو كما هو مشاهد الان
بشكل واضح جدا
طيب مصطفى هل هنالك اي ابنيه مدمره قريبه
من هذا الطريق ام لا هذه المنطقه التي انت
متواجد فيها منطقه زراعيه خاليا صح
التعبير نعم الطرف الاخر هنالك قريه على
يمين لكن هي يعني هذه القريه امامي لو
تترك لي المجال انا اتحرك باتجاهها قليلا
تفضل الكاميرا معك
تماما ساتحرك واغير كاميرا كي تشاهد اكثر
الان
هذا اثار الدمار هناك ابنيه متساقطه ليس
ما افصلها ثوان معدوده
[موسيقى]
يعني نحن نرى بام العين حجم الدمار
مصطفى يعني دمار هائل يعني يعني حتى يضيع
عن فم التعبير لاصف هذا حجم الدمار وحجم
يعني الكارثه منذ خمسه ايام ساترك لك
الكلمه تفضل مصطفى
كما تشاهد الان هذه الفرق المعنيه ايضا
باعاده تاهيل الطريق على يساري امامي
تماما في الصوره ربما الان صار اصبحت
مشاهده من قبل على الشاشه
جرافات مدحله ايضا كذلك ايضا مركبه تحمل
على جلب الحصى من اجل كبس الدفع الطريق
مجددا من اجل اعاده ترميمه كمسار اولي ومن
ثم يقوم باعاده تعميره ترميم الطرف الاخر
لكن ساضطر الخروج من هنا
هذا التصدعات الان في الطريق واضحه التي
اتحرك عليها هنا خطر جدا يعني لو شاهدت
هنا
مصطفى ارجو ان تلتزم الحذر يعني لانه يعني
انت يعني ان تمشي على هذه على هذا الاسفلت
المدمر والمتشقق مثلا خطره جدا ولكن كي
يرى المشاهد حجم الدمار الذي
تهدد حياتك ارجوك ان شاء الله لا لا ابدا
لا لا ابدا ضمن الاحتياطات الواجبه وهنالك
منازل على يميني كي اريك اياها ايضا طبعا
الاسفلت طبقه تقريبا حوالي 30 الى 35 سم
كما تشاهد هذا الانهيار هنا على يساري
تماما
لو ذهبت بالكاميرا هكذا الان
معدات التقنيه بسيطه ولكن الصوره توضح
اكثر من اللسان يعجز عنها اللسان كما
تشاهد هذا الانهيار هنا الانهيار داخل
قرابه
داخل الطريق
هنا تشاهد الان هذه الابنيه التي تحدثت
عنها قبل قليل بجانب مزرعه تشاهد هنا
هنغار انقلب بشكل كامل وعلى الطرف الاخر
هنا هذه اللوحات الارشاديه هذه اللوحه
تشير الى ان مدينه انطاكيا على مسافه
قريبه او
ليست واضحه بالنسبه لي هذه المنطقه هذه
المنطقه على يسار اسمها حجي باشا هذا
الانهيار هنا واضح ايضا هنا الطرف الاخر
على الاسفلت الذي امشي عليه الطرف هذا
اليمين كما تشاهد هنالك العربات هنالك
ايضا المعدات التقنيه التي جلبت من اجلها
مباني متصدعه مباني مائله
كما تشاهد طيب مصطفى في هذه المنطقه هل
وصلتك اي معلومات عن حجم الخسائر تحديدا
البشريه وما اذا كان هنالك مستشفيات قريبه
نقل اليها المصابون يعني ايضا تعطينا يعني
فكره عن هذه المنطقه من حيث حجم الخسائر
وليس فقط الخسائر الماديه التي نشاهدها
بام العين نعم ساقترب قليلا ربما اصل الى
الجهات المعنيه بعمليه الاصلاح قد اصل
احصل على معلومات ايضا ولربما قد يشاركوني
في المقابله فيتحدثون اللغه العربيه لان
المظهر امامي صراحه
منظر مهول جدا لا يمكن وصفه وللاسف يعني
الصوره تتحرك لكن الطريق الذي اتحرك عليه
وعد جدا ونصاب ايضا
يعني حجم الدمار في هذا الطريق يعني اعاده
تاهيله من اجل ان تنقل المساعدات
او او او او الفرق الاغاثيه فهذا يحتاج
الى وقت طويل
نعم نعم هنالك طريق موازي على الطرف الاخر
لكنه ربما لا يظهر بالكاميرا الان هذه
سياره مساعدات كما تشاهد الان على يساري
سياره شحن مساعدات على الطرف الاخر لكن
بعيده قليل الشيء
تماما هذه هذا الطريق هو الموازي الذي تم
تحويل فيه الطريق المسافه كنت اعتقدها
قرابه كيلو متر ولكن على ما يبدو اكثر من
اثنين كيلو متر كما تشاهد الان هذه
المباني متصدعات الطرف الاخر هنا
المظهر عند الجسر تماما تصدعات واضحه
التشققات في الارض كما تشاهد هنا هذا
التصدع هنا تماما انهيار
حتى تكون تشتغل
تتحدث العربيه
ممكن تصور هون تمام شكرا لا يتحدث اللغه
العربيه للاسف كان من الممكن ان نفهم منه
اكثر وسمح لي بالدخول ايضا الى الداخل كي
اشاهد المنظر كيف حصل مع الجسر طبعا
صعب جدا وصفه يعني انا امشي مصطفى ارجوك
لا ارجوك ارجوك لا تمشي على الجسر يا
مصطفى مصطفى اسمعني
يعني ولكن المشهد من هنا خطير
لا يعني ارجو ان لا تعرض نفسك لاي مخاطر
ان شاء الله لن اتعرض ان شاء الله لكن انا
هنا احد اوتاد الجسر هذا لكي اوضح لكم شكل
الجسر هنا تلاحظ حتى الفرق المعنيه تذهب
يعني انا اتحدث هنا عن المشاه فقط وليس
المركبات لا يوجد هنالك مركبات مطلقا لكن
هنا انظر حجم الدمار
بجانب الجسر اخ يا الله
ايضا ساعود قليلا من هنا
تشاهد هكذا هذا كذا المنظر يعني الصوره
تعجز يعجز اللسان عن وصفها صراحه استاذ
محمد شيء لا يصدق مطلقا هنا هذه الزاويه
الاولى من حضاره جسر كما تشاهد من هذا هذا
المستوى الطبيعي للشارع الذي اقف عليه
الان ساتحدث عن امام الكاميرا كي تكون كي
تكون مشهد اقرب بالنسبه لكم تلاحظ الان
خلف الجزر هذا المستوى الطبيعي للطريق
بينما الانهيار هنا من جانبي على اليمين
انظر كيف هو الانهيار الطرف الاخر هناك
ارتفاع الجسد نفسه اعطى عضلات اعضاضه
الجسر ما زال كانه كانه قطعه كانه قطعه من
العجين يعني كان الزلزال يعني جعله مثلا
الورق يعني يلتف عنها على بعضه بس مصطفى
باقي الطرقات الاخرى هي على هذه الشاكله
ام لا فقط في هذه المنطقه هذه فقط هنا
تقريبا اثنين كيلو متر كما اشاهدها بعين
المجرده الطرف الاخر يعني ساقترب من الطرف
الاخر لانه ربما تكون الاضرار اقل من هذا
الطرف الذي اقف عليه علما باني لو كنت
لوحدي لخاطرت ولكن من اجل القناه
سواء كنت لوحدك او مش لوحدك يا مصطفى
الان ساعود على الطرف الاخر كما تشاهد
بس الطرف صيانه طبعا فوق هذا الجسر يسمى
جسر الحديد هنا نهر على ما اعتقد مياه
يعني يظهر حجما الانهيار الذي حصل وادى
الى
ضاضات المياه وضغط هذه المياه من اي
المصطفى فقط هذه المياه التي نراها من اين
سواق هي سواق من اجل المنطقه الزراعيه
طبعا كما تشاهد
هذه لكن هي بالاصل ارفع يعني حجمها اصغر
من ذلك لكن عمليه الانهيارات ودخول المياه
من الطرف الاخر هذا يؤكد على انها كان حد
حجم الانهيار كبير جدا كما تلاحظ هنا
الابنيه ربما افضل ولكن ساقترب الى
الزاويه الاولى التي تشاهدها هنا يعني
الان يعمل على اعاده ترميم الطريق الان
امامي
الان امامي كما تشاهد الان حفريات تعمل هل
تتم بالسرعه المطلوبه ام تراها بطيئه يعني
عمليات اعاده الترميم او اصلاح هذا الطريق
مصطفى
الانصاف في ذلك اعتقد بان بطء العمليات هو
نظرا لان هنالك اولويات في مدينه انطاكا
على سبيل المثال هنالك الكثير من الضحايا
ما زالت تحت الانقاذ وقبل قليل تبعت
الكثير من النشرات مع منفدك الاستاذ عمار
الهندي كيف يوصف الحال
صراحه يعني يعجز اللسان عن الوصف يعني انا
الان على طرف الطريق من هنا ساضطر اطلع
اغادر على الطرف الاخر
سبب انهيارات التي هي بجانبي ايضا
الاجهزه المعنيه بسلامه الطريق تعمل وهنا
تلاحظ ايضا انظر هنا كيف هذا
مصطفى مصطفى ارجوك يعني اول شيء شكرا لك
على على نقل هذه المشاهد للاسف انا مضطر
لان هنالك حديث مباشر ومؤتمر صحفي للرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان من ملاطيا ننتقل
ونستمع ما يقول لرئيس التركي
تعمل بشكل فعال في كل المناطق وفي كل
المدن المنكوبه الجيش والقوات الامنيه
وقوات الدركي يؤمنون المنطقه من الناحيه
الامنيه كما يساهمون في عمليات البحث
والانقاد وايضا تقديم المساعدات
الذين يعملون هنا يتالفون من 100 الف
وواحد واربعين واربعمائه
عامه مع العاملين المحليين والعاملين ايضا
من هذه
توافدوا من عدد كبير من الدول طبعا هناك
مطابخ مؤقته متحركه بالاضافه الى
المخيمات التي تم طبعا هناك عدد كبير من
الفرقه التي تقدم الخدمات
الى
جينا من هذه الزلازل يتم تامين الطعام
بشكل كبير يتم توزيع هذه الاطعمه على
وجبات خلال اليوم هناك ايضا مبادرات مدنيه
ليقدموا هذه الوجبات
منها عينيه ومنها نقديه طبعا نرى ايضا
مئات السيارات وشاحنات منها محمله بمواد
غذائيه ومنها ايضا تحتوي على افران متحركه
لصنع الخبز هنا وتوزيعه على
اللجنه من المتضررين من هذه الزلازل نشكر
كل المبادرات نشكر كل المواطنين الذين
وقفوا الى جانب الاهالي هنا وقفوا الى
جانبنا نحن ايضا كما تعلمون انه تم تخصيص
ميزانيه
وتعيين ميزانيه
لتقديمها الى الناجين بشكل اولي الى
المتضررين من هذه الزلازل وهذا يعني
سنبدا بتقديم 15 الف ليره تركيه الان الى
كل عائله تضررت من الزلازل كما اننا
مساعدات النقديه
الاف ليره تركيه ليستاجروا في اماكن اخرى
وايضا
بقرابه 2000 ليره تركيه
للذين سيخرجون الى مدن اخرى وياخذون منازل
هناك ويدفعون
الاشجار فيها او في المدن التي لم تتضرر
في المدني ذاتها كما اننا نهدف الى اعاده
اعمار هذه المدينه في اقصر وقت ممكن بعد
ازاله هذه
هذا الركام وطبعا ازاله كل
الذي يتواجد هنا في هذه المناطق وفي هذه
المدن سنعيد
هذه المدن واتخذنا كل التدابير الممكنه
كما اننا قد التعليمات في رفع الانقاذ
لاقصى وقتا ممكن وبعد ذلك سيساهم في ازاله
الرخام واعاده الاعمال وطبعا بدا الاعمار
فيها في اقصد وقتا ممكن التسليمها خلال
عام واحد وطبعا نحن فقط نطلب منكم ان
تصبروا لمده عام وباذنك على خلال العام
سنسلمكم هذه المنازل
من مواطنين لوحدهم
الى جانب الجميع
نحن نعمل ان تثقوا بنا وانت تثقوا
باعمالنا هناك بعض الشبكات الاستغلاليه
نرجو منكم الا تستمعوا اليهم ابدا هذه
الفتره لا تسمح للاستغلات
هذه الفتره هي فتره تضامن علينا ان نتضامن
علينا ان نكون قلبا واحدا علينا
نقف مع شعبنا كتفا الى كتف وبالتالي هناك
بعض المنصات على موقع التواصل الاجتماعي
يقوم بنشر بعض الاخبار الكاذبه ويستفزون
الشعب ويستفزون ايضا عواطف الشعبيه هذه
المرحله لا تسمح لهم ارجوكم لا تسمحون لهم
هناك فتره صعبه نحن نعيش هذه الفتره نعيش
هذه التحديات هناك بعض المستغلين التجاريه
وسياسيا وعاطفيا لا نسمح لهم ولكن الوجدان
الانساني يسجلهم الان اعلنا حاله الطوارئ
كما تعلمون من اجل
الكارثه هناك عمليات نهب المراكز التجاريه
والمحال التجاريه لن نسمح لذلك الشعب
التركي لن يمس هذه
السلعه
لو طالبوا بهذه السلع والمحتاجين لو طلبوا
بهذه السلع فكانت هذه الاسواق بالفعل كرست
كل موادها كل سلعها الى هذه لماذا نحن
نقدمها المساعدات لان الشعب التركي الشعب
وفي الشعب التركي شعب له الوفاء المسؤوليه
ودائما يساعد المظلومين
لا يستطيع ان يبقى
هنا مكتوب في الايدي امام هذا هذه الكوارث
وهذا الزلزال وبالتالي
[موسيقى]
جيدا ان بعد العسر يسرا وبعد كل ظلام هناك
ضوء هناك بصيص امل فهناك
فرج باذن الله تعالى نحن نعاني الان في
فتره عصيبه نعيش في فتره عصيبه جدا باذنه
تعالى
سنتغلب على هذه المسار طبعا
كما حصل في الكوارت وكما حصل في ازرا
كل المواطنين
واسال الله ان
شاء الله
[موسيقى]
في هذه المناطق افاد هنا الوزراء هنا
العاملين هنا
الجميع يعمل على قدم هنا دون كلل اول اشكر
الجميع
فليوفقنا الله ويعيننا باذنه تعالى
اذا هذه هي نظره الكرام كانت كلمه للرئيس
اتركي من مدينه ملاطيا
[موسيقى]
قافله اولى من المساعده مؤلفه من ست
شاحنات دخلت الى مناطق سيطره فصائل
المعارضه في شمال غرب سوريا من تركيا عبر
معبر باب الهواء الحدودي
واوضحت المنظمه الدوليه للهجره ان القافله
تحمل بطانيات وفرشات وخيمن ومستلزمات
طوارئ ومصابيح تعمل بالطاقه الشمسيه وذلك
لتغطيه احتياجات ما لا يقل عن 5000 شخص
الان منظمه الخوض البيضاء اعربت عن خيبه
املها معتبره ان المساعدات الامميه التي
يجري الحديث عن دخولها هي مساعدات دوريه
وقد توقفت خلال الايام الاولى من الزلزال
والان تم استئنافها
على صعيد اخر كشف مسؤول تركيا ان انقره
تناقش اعاده فتح معبر حدودي يؤدي الى
مناطق خاضعه لسيطره الحكومه السوريه ما
يتيح ارسال مساعدات الاغاثه من الزلزال
مباشره الى هذه المناطق بعد عقد من العدا
وقال المسؤول ان تركيا تدرس وايضا فتحه
معبر اخر الى منطقه ادلب السوريه الخاضعه
لسيطره المعارضه
ينضم الي مجددا لمزيد من المتابعه
والتغطيه من مطار غازي عنتاب موفد العربيه
عبد المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن اهلا وسهلا
بك عبد المحسن اول شيء انقل لنا الصوره
جديد ما لديك خصوصا يعني ما قيل انه
عمليات الاغاثه تفتقر الى المعدات اللازمه
والمخصصه
مثل هكذا
ماسي او كوارث كالزلزال الان يجري الحديث
انه اتت معدات سواء معدات كبيره او ثقيله
مخصصه للحفر لو تعطينا الصوره لو سمحت
نعم طالب بالفعل كان الوضع
كارثي اليوم حيث شاهدنا في عدد من مناطق
المتفرقه هنا في غازي عنتاب بعض المنازل
لم يتم العمل على ازاله الركام والبحث عن
ناجين الا خلال ربما هذا اليوم جلست ثلاثه
ايام لم يتم الحفر والبحث عن ناجين نظرا
لقله المعدات
وكثره البيوت والمنازل المهدمه فبالتالي
تتجه الانظار الى مطار غازي عنتاب الذي
وصلت عبره عدد كبير من المساعدات اليوم
نتحدث عن مساعدات اغاثيه دوائيه
وايوائيه بالاضافه الى المعدات والفرق
الانقاديه شاهدت عديد من الفرق الانقاديه
اليوم وصلت من مختلف انحاء العالم في مطار
غازي عنتاب الذي انقلب الى خليه نحل
يستقبل كل هذه
المعدات والادوات الغذائيه
والاغاثيه بشكل عام ليتم ت مباشره عبر عدد
من الشاحنات الى
المحتاجين والمتضررين كما تشاهد في الصوره
وصلت قبل قليل هذا الان طائرات او معدات
عفوا
للطائره التي تحمل المعدات للدفاع المدني
السعودي فريق البحث والانقاذ السعودي الذي
وصل بمعدات ثقيله تشتمل ايضا على
معدات ووسائل البحث او نتحدث عن الكلاب
البوليسيه التي يتم استخدامها في عمليات
البحث عن ناجين بالاضافه الى شاحنات محمله
بتقنيات الحديثه وسيارات خاصه بوسائل
البحث والسيارات ايضا للقياده الميدانيه
للتنقل بين المناطق بالاضافه الى طائره
اخرى ستصل او وصلت فعليا وهي في الجانب
الاخر من المطار تحمل على متنهاد تقريبا
96 من المختصين
بالانقاذ من الدفاع المدني من فريق
وصلوا في طائره ليست بعيده من الان و
سينزلون بعد قليل ليبداوا مهامه عبد
المحسن
سنعود اليك بالطبع في سياق هذه التغطيه
شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه المتابعه من
مطار غازي عنتاب
اعزائي المشاهدين بعد مرور نحو 103 ساعات
على محاصرته تحت الانقاض رجل يبلغ من
العمر 66 عاما ينجو من الموت بعد العثور
عليه من قبل قوات الانقاذ في تركيا
[موسيقى]
هذا وتوقع التقارير غربيه استمرار كارثه
الزلزال في تركيا بسبب مخاطر اخرى حتى بعد
معالجه الجرحى وانتشال جثث الضحايا من تحت
الانقاض هذه التقارير نبهت الى امكانيه
بروز تداعيات اخرى بفعل الزلزال مثل نقص
المياه النظيفه وتعطل شبكه الصرف الصحي
فضلا عن انخفاض حاد في درجات الحراره
وتلوث المياه الجوفيه لافته الى ان سكان
المناطق المتضرره من الزلزال يواجهون
صعوبات في العثور على المياه الصالحه
للشرب ويخشون انتشار الامراض لا سيما
المعديه منها كما تخشى المنظمات الانسانيه
خصوصا انتشار وباء الكوليرا الذي عاد
للظهور قبل فتره
في سوريا
المتحدث الرسمي باسم منظمه اليونسف في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا عمار
عمار قال ان الاطفال يمرون بظروف ماساويه
في المناطق التي وقع بها الزلزال في تركيا
وسوريا وشدد المسؤول عن ان الاوضاع
الانسانيه في سوريا على وجه التحديد صعبه
جدا حيث اشارت التقديرات قبل الزلزال الى
ان هناك نحو ثلثي السكان بحاجه الى تقديم
المساعده والعون ومن بينهم سبعه ملايين
طفل يحتاجون الى المساعده الانسانيه التي
تتركز على توفير التغذيه المناسبه والصحه
والحمايه ومياه الشرب الصالحه وغيرها وقد
جاء الزلزال ليفاقم من هذه الماساه حسب
قوله
[موسيقى]
يلا يلا حباب حمودي يلا يلا حباب الى جنب
الان ينضم الي لمزيد من المتابعه المدير
العام للجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر روبير
مارتيني اهلا وسهلا بك يعني الصوره مبكيه
مفجعه ولكن مع ذلك ساسالك اي تقييم يعطيه
الصليب الاحمر للوضع في اليوم الخامس من
هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب مناطق شرق المتوسط
وهل الصوره ماساويه تماما ام لا ثمت بارقه
امل من وصول المساعدات في الوقت المحدد
الى محتاجينها
الوضع ماساوي جدا ونحن باللهجه دوليه
لصليب الاحمر نتعاطف مع جميع السوريين
اليوم
يجب ان لا ننسى ان جميع السكان في سوريا
ازمه بعد تلو الاخرى على مدار اكثر من عقد
وصولا الى اللحظه الراهنه من نزاع تسبب في
تبعات انسانيه كارثيه الى جائحه الكوفيد
19 وازمه اقتصاديه طاحنه تفشي وباء
الكوليرا اخر سنه السنه والان كارثه
طبيعيه مع هذا الزلزال التي تقع في
الحقيقه ظروف مناخيه قاسيه جدا وحتى قبل
وقوع الزلزال هذا الاسبوع عدى النزاع في
سوريا الى اقتراب البنيه التحتيه الاساسيه
والخدمات العامه في ارجاء البلاد الى نقطه
انهيار وهذا هذا هذا هذه مشكله كبيره وهو
وضع يتطلب المزيد من المساعدات من الجهات
الانسانيه ما
الذي تان وحجم الاستجابه لنداءاتكم لتقديم
المساعده سواء من الدول او المنظمات
اللجنه الدوليه تتواجد في سوريا منذ 12
سنه بشده تعمل يد باليد مع المتطوعين
الهلال الاحمر السوري واستجابه اللجنه
الدوليه لصليب الاحمر فورا للاحتياجات
الانسانيه الاشد الحاحا وشمل ذلك تلبيه
الاحتياجات الطبيه حيث تعمل الان فرق
متعدده على الارض لتقييم الاوضاع واعداد
عمليه استجابه قويه مع تدفق المساعدات الى
سوريا التي هي تتواجد عنا والمزيد من
المساعدات تصل الى سوريا
ومن الاهميه بما كان ونحن نشهد فصول هذه
الاحداث الماساويه الا ننسى محنه السكان
في عموم البلاد فالاحتياجات تتزايد في ظل
نقص التمويل المتخصص للمساعدات وللاسف طيب
ما الذي يحتاجه المتضررون الان وبشكل
العاجل وفي حال تامنت المساعدات ما الضامن
بانها ستصل الى تستحقين يا استاذ روبير
نحن نعرف انه ما زالت في مناطق يعني بتعرف
في حرب اهليه في سوريا استمرت عشر سنوات
في مناطق خاضعه للحكومه في مناطق خاضعه
للمعارضه انتم تستطيعون العمل في المنطقه
بنفس الشروط وفي تسهيل من الجميع لمهمتكم
ام لا في مناطق من الصعوبه ان تعملوا فيها
بالفعل ونحن سنمد يد العون لكل من يحتاج
الى المساعده حيثما كان واينما وجد اما
بشان الوصول المساعدات فيجب الا توضع اي
عراقيه امام وصول المساعدات الانسانيه
واوضحنا ذلك لجميع الاطراف
على مدى سنوات النزاع يلي تفضلت وذاكرته
ونكرر دعوتنا اليوم ويجب ان تمنح
اللجنه الدوليه
وتمنح الدوله السوريه والجماعات المسلحه
الاولويه للاحتياجات الانسانيه الهائله
وندعوهم الى وضع القضايا السياسيه جانبا
هل تمت اطراف تعرق الوصول المساعدات وفق
معلوماتك
نحن نعمل عشاء
بمنطقه ادلب مع الاطراف المعنيه في تحديات
ولكن نعمل ونتامل انه
القضايا السياسيه حطو توضع جنبا والاولويه
الانسانيه حتكون
[موسيقى]
مسؤوليه المعارضه لتسهيل مهمتكم ام لا في
بعض
الامكنه الاتصالات مقطوعه وان كنت اسالك
اسئله تفصيليه لا ولكن المشاهد يريد ان
يعرف خصوصا عملكم في المناطق التي هي
خاضعه الى حد ما لسيطره مقاتلي المعارضه
نريد ان نعرف كيف تتحركون هناك اللجنه
الدوليه على على اتصال مع جميع الاطراف
اليوم الاتصال مع المعارضه في ادلب نواجه
بعض التحديات ولكن نتامل انه هالاتصال
حيكون حيكون ايجابي وحيسمح لنا نوصل ونؤدي
الاستجابه الانسانيه طيب
انا سانقل لك المشهد وانت اكيد عم بتابع
يعني المشهد مهول مفجع مبكي شاهدنا في
اطفال فقدوا ذويهم مش بذويهم حتى اقاربهم
طب هؤلاء مش بس بلا ماوى يعني من يرعاهم
في ناس يهيمون على وجوههم
طيب هؤلاء انا اتحدث فقط عن الاطفال طيب
هؤلاء كيف يتم
ان يحتضنهم احد ان يرعاهم احد خصوصا في
هذه الفتره هل لديكم اي داله على ذلك
الحاله مبكيه
وصعبه للغايه يعني ما ننسى انه كمان
يجد عدد كبير من المفقودين من النزاع
ونعرف هالشي باللجنه الدوليه لصليب الاحمر
فبالنسبه للاطفال اكيد المجتمعات هي اللي
استجابت باول ساعات النزاع واكيد نحن هلا
دورنا انه مع الهلال الاحمر السوري مساعده
النازحين اللي زاد عددهم قبل الزلزال كان
في سبعه مليون نازح بسوريا وهلا اكيد عدد
النازحين مع هالزلزال والكارثه يزداد
واكيد الاستجابه الانسانيه لازم تحط
كاولويه المساعده الاطفال
في كمان في موضوع هو مساله المياه يعني
كانت تفشل كوليرا في عدد من المناطق في
سوريا في السنه في السنه الماضيه الان مع
هذا الزلزال وعدم التوفر مياه نظ فخصوص
وكذلك مياه الشفا في مخاطر من عوده
الكوليرا ان يضرب مجددا تحديدا الاطفال
هون هل لديكم اي معلومات
اكيد نحن بنعرف انه 50% من امدادات المياه
والصرف الصحي
لا تعمل على نحو جيد وهذا الشيء قبل
الزلزال فاليوم اكيد التحديات بالنسبه
للمياه
والصرف الصحي تحديات بعد اكبر وكل العمل
يلي قامت فيه اللجنه الدوليه والهلال
الاحمر السوري خلال هذه السنين لازم نعززه
اكثر
لتفادي تفشي الكوليراي اللي هو اكيد
خطر خطر قوي جدا حاليا طيب وانت تتحدث سيز
روبير الحكومه السوريه تقول انه تم السماح
لمساعدات لدخول مساعدات انسانيه لمناطق
المعارضه بالتنسيق مع الصليب الاحمر
الدولي هل يمكن تاكيد هذه المعلومات
نحن على اتصال وفي عنا امدادات صحيه عم
توصل على سوريا وعم نوزعها الاماكن مثل
مثل حلب اللاذقيه طرطوس وفرحنا على الارض
عم تعمل حاليا من جناب المدير العام للجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر روبير مارديني شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
[موسيقى]
الخوض البيضاء اعلنت انها ستواصل البحث عن
ناجين تحت الانقاض رغم صعوبه الامر
فالزلزال يدخل يومه الخامس ما يعادل 120
ساعه
حتميا فرص نجاه العالقين تحت الانقاض شبه
معدومه حيث تعتبر اول اثنتين وسبعين ساعه
بعد الزلزال اي اول ثلاثه ايام اطارا
زمنيا حرجا
وينخفض بعد ذلك معدل البقاء على قيد
الحياه الى ما بين خمسه الى عشره بالمئه
وبحسب خبراء الكوارث الطارئه تعتبر
الاثنتان والسبعون ساعه الاولى بعد
الكارثه هي الفتره التي يمكن للانسان ان
يعيش خلالها بقوه جسديه دون طعام او ماء
يبلغ معدل البقاء على قيد الحياه 90% خلال
اول 24 ساعه وخمسين الى 60% بين 25 و 48
ساعه وعشرين الى ثلاثين بالمئه بين 49
واثنتين وسبعين ساعه اما بعد الاثنتين
وسبعين ساعه فيكون معدل البقاء على قيد
الحياه ما بين خمسه الى عشره بالمئه او
اقل
وفي الكوارث عاده ما يتم الغاء معظم جهود
الانقاذ بعد خمسه الى سبعه ايام فالعثور
على شخص ما خلال هذه الساعات الذهبيه كما
يقال هي مساله حياه او موت وتعتبر سباقا
مع الزمن
الى متى يمكن للعالقين البقاء تحت الانقاض
وضعيه الشخصيه عند حدوث الانهيار فمن
المهم تواجد الشخص في مكان بحمايه جسديه
الحصول على الماء والهواء فهما اساسيان
للبقاء على قيد الحياه
ومن الضروري عدم الاصابه بالجفاف لرفع
احتماليه البقاء على قيد الحياه
بعض التقديرات تشير الى امكانيه بعض الناس
العيش دون ماء لمده تتراوح بين الثلاثه
وسبعه ايام
مستوى الاصابات فقدان الدم او الكسور
يقللان احتماليه البقاء حيا لاكثر من يوم
خصوصا اذا تعرض الشخص لصدمه في الراس او
اصابات في العمود الفقري او الصدر او تضرر
العضلات نتيجه السحق
الظروف الجويه خبراء يقولون ان الظروف
الشتاء تجعل الوضع اسوا بكثير
السرعه التي يحدث بها انخفاض حراره الجسم
ستعتمد على مدى عزله الشخص او مقدار
الماوى الذي يتمتع به ولكن في نهايه
المطاف سيصاب العديد من الاشخاص الاقل حظا
بانخفاض حراره الجسم في ظل هذه الظروف
القوه العقليه والنفسيه خبراء يشددون على
اهميه الحفاظ على الاراده النفسيه
والعقليه المركزه على البقاء قد يكون امرا
حاسما للبقاء على قيد الحياه كما قالوا
انه من المهم السيطره على النفس والتقليل
من الذعر للتقليل من الحركه الجسديه
لتوفير الطاقه
تعال تعال
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معي من القاهره الان منطقه باسم برنامج
الاغذيه العالميه في الشرق الاوسط ريم ندى
ريم اهلا وسهلا بك برنامج الاغذيه اعلن ان
مخزونه بدا ينفذ في الشمال السوري خصوصا
في هذا الظرف الدقيق اولا ما العمل وكيف
يمكن رفد المخزون بسرعه لان الوقت يعني لا
يحتمل
هو دعني فقط اصحح هو يعني لم ينفذ المخزون
ولكن هناك
لانه بدانا بالتوزيع امس بدانا بتوزيع
المساعدات الغذائيه وصلت المساعدات
الغذائيه الى 43 الف شخص في الشمال السوري
منهم 25 الف شخص في شمال غربي سوريا الان
هناك ما يكفي حصص غذائيه طارئه تكفي لمئه
الف شخص وهناك حصص غذائيه شهريه تكفي
لمليون ونصف المليون شخص
السرعه في الوصول الى هذه المناطق هو امر
حاسم جدا للوصول الى الاشخاص الناجين نحن
الان نتحدث عن الاشخاص الناجين الذين هم
احتياجاتهم عوضا عن احتياجاتهم النفسيه
ولكن احتياجاتهم للغذاء هي بمثابه احتياج
اساسي لاي انسان في اي ظرف فهذه هي اولويه
البرنامج
الوصول الى كل المحتاجين ست ندى ام لا ثمت
عراقيل
شركاء برنامج الاغبياء العالميه امس قاموا
بتوزيع المساعدات الغذائيه
المناشده برنامج الاغبياء العالميه سهوله
الوصول بان المخزون كل مخزون يجب ان يتم
اعاده
تعبئته او اعاده اعاده ايصال المساعدات
نحن الان هناك شاحنات عبرت شاحنات تابعه
للامم المتحده عبرت
المعبر باب الهوى ولكن يعني قبل قبل عامين
كانت هناك ثلاثه معابر تعمل لادخال
المساعدات من الجنوب السوري عفوا من
الجنوب التركي للشمال السوري فهذا هو ما
يعني يتمناه برنامج الاغذيه العالمي هو ان
تكون المساعدات التي تذهب الى منطقه شمال
سوريا تذهب من جميع الجهات من الداخل
السوري من كل المعابر على طول
مع تركيا وهو
ما نهدف اليه وما نناشد كل الاطراف مساعده
عاملين الاغاثه وخاصه الامم المتحده على
التمكن من تحقيقه
بتعرفي هذه يعني هذه الماساه ستطول
تداعياتها ستريم هل لديكم يعني اي تصور
لحجم المساعدات التي تحتاجونها من اجل سد
هذه الفجوه يعني نحن نتحدث عن مئات الالاف
بدون ماوى بدون غذاء وهذا الامر قد يستمر
هل لديكم اي تصور او اي خطه
اكيد في البدايه الان برنامج الاغذيه
العالميه
يقدر ان هناك حوالي 900 الف شخص في كلا
البلد بلدين يحتاجون الى المساعدات
الغذائيه يعمل برنامج الاغذيه العالميه
على مساعده البلديات في الجنوب التركي على
توفير قام بايصال الغذاء حتى يساعد
البلديات على تقديم الطعام الساخن يوميا
200,000 شخص من المتضررين ايضا هناك
مساعدات غذائيه ل 42 الف نازح تركي ولاجئ
سوري في مناطق الايواء في الجنوب التركي
وصلت هذه الاغذيه بالفعل وطبعا في في في
الايام والاسابيع القادمه سيقوم البرنامج
باعاده تقييم الوضع
للوقوف على الاعداد التي تحتاج المساعدات
الغذائيه الاضافيه طيب ستريم سؤال اخير
تحديدا في في سوريا
في يعني في مناطق قادعه لمقاتلي المعارضه
المناط قاضي على الحكومه عم نسمع تبادل
وتقادف للاتهامات انه المساعدات اللي
بتيجي من برنامج الاغذيه العالمي
المقاتلين المعارضه بيتهموا انه الحكومه
تمنع وصول هذه المساعدات الى المناطق
الخاضعه للسياراتهم الحكومه تتهم ايضا
المقاتلين المعرض بالعكس فصحت ما يجري على
هذه المعابر وهل لديكم اتصال مع الطرفين
في البدايه برنامج الاغذيه العالميه يعني
يدعو الى وضع السياسه والاتهامات
والترشقات جانبا حتى نهتم بالعمل الذي
يعني يتعين علينا فعله الان وهو الوصول
الى الاشخاص الذين يحتاجون الى المساعدات
الغذائيه هذا هذه هي الاولويه
المساعدات الانسانيه والمنظمات الانسانيه
لا تعرف الحدود ولا تعرف الفصائل هي تعرف
فقط ان هناك اشخاص يحتاجون الى المساعده
سواء المساعده الغذائيه او المساعده في
توفير اي شيء يحتاجونه من من حيث
الاحتياجات الانسانيه خاصه التي خلفتها
هذه الكارت
يعني نحن محكومون بالامل والرجاء دائما
ستريم من القاهره الناطق باسم برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي في الشرق الاوسط ريم ندى
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
هذا هو توقعت وكاله فيتش للتصنيف
الائتماني ان تتجاوز الخسائر الاقتصاديه
جراء الزلزال مليارين دولار وقد تصل الى
اربعه مليارات دولار او اكثر حيث تعرضت
الاف المباني بما في ذلك منازل ومستشفيات
فضلا عن طرق وخطوط انابيب وبنيه تحتيه
اخرى لاضرار جسيمه واشارت وكاله اداره
الكوارث التركيه الى ان لديها
11,342 بلاغا عن انهيار مباني سكنيه وقد
تم تاكيد خمسه الاف
775 منها في تركيا تحديدا قال الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان
644 مبنى دمرت بسبب الزلزال وان
944 مبدا انهار في غاز عنتاب وحدها متعهدا
باستكمال اعاده الاعمار في المنطقه في
غضون عام واحد
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان قال خلال
جولاته في ايدي اليمن وملاطيا ان الدول
ستعمل على مساعده اقارب المتوفين جراء
الزلزال وعلى اعاده الاعمار في اقصر وقت
ممكن
اود ان اؤكد لاقارب المتوفين اننا
سنساعدكم في كل شيء على المتضررين الا
يقلقوا ابدا سنعيد الاعمار بكل الطرق وفي
اقصر وقت ممكن نحن نعمل على تكريس
امكانيات الدوله لتقديم المساعدات
مع من اسطنبول الان المحلل السياسي اوكتاي
يلمز للحديث في السياسه وليس في موضوع
الزلزال لانه نحن نغطي موضوع الزلزال على
مدار الساعه منذ ثلاثه ايام استاذ
اولا سمعت الرئيس التركي يتهم اطرافا
داخليا
باستغلال الماساه
وهنالك حديث ايضا عن انعكاسات سياسيه
ستكون على حكومه حزب العداله والتنميه
خصوصا وان البعض يتهم الحكومه بان
استجابتها كانت بطيئه
مع هذه الماساه اي انعكاسات سياسيه برايك
سنراها في الايام المقبله
تحيه طيبه نعم يعني استغلال مثل هذه
الكارثه الكارثه الوطنيه لاغراض سياسيه
مرفوض سواء كان
للجانب الحكومي او للمعارضه مرفوض تماما
يعني لا حاجه اعتقد الى تكرار مثل هذه
التصريحات
يعني البلد يظهر وحده وتضامن
واستنفار كبير جدا
لا انا يعني مواقف السياسيين
للاستفاده او للاتهام الطرف الاخر
في وقت الحرج والمحنه هذا من جانب من جانب
اخر يعني المفروض استغلال الحادثه مرفوض
للجانبين للحكومه
وللمعارضه يعني نحن في نظام ديمقراطي من
حق المعارضه
يا سيدي الكريم لا يمكن القول ان القول ان
هذه الاحداث
لصالح الحكومه او لضدها الناس
ليسوا جهال سيقيمون اداء الحكومه نعم يعني
هناك سؤال هل استنفرت الحكومه جميع
الامكانياتها واستنفرت
لمواجهه
لاستغاثه
المنكوبين نعم السؤال الاخر هل كافيه
كانت
الاستنفار في مستوى الحادث لا لا نستطيع
ان نقول نعم كانت هناك بعض النقص والخلل
وما الى ذلك من المشاكل وهذا اعتقد امر
طبيعي الى حد ما اليوم الاول
الاستجابه ربما كانت بالدرجه الاقل كان
الحديث حول التدخل واسراح سته او سبعه
الاف عنصر لانقاذ
المنكوبين في اليوم التالي زاد العدد
حوالي الى 40 وخمسين الف عنصر للانقاذ وفي
يوم الثالث كان الحديث
مئه عن 100 الف عنصر واردوغان بنفسه اقر
انه كانت هناك بعض
النقص وما الى بعض المشاكل والسلبيات ولكن
نحن امام كارثه كبرى حقيقه توصف
بانها كارثه القرن تشمل المنطقه واسع جدا
نتحدث عن عشر رجال في النهايه ان سيقيمون
لا احد لا احد يناقش استاذ
بكل المعايير كامله الاوصاف هذه الكارثه
والماساه خصوصا المشاهد التي عم نشاهدها
تكرارا على الشاشه يعني مشاهد تدمي القلب
ما الذي تحتاجه الحكومه التركيه بشكل عاجل
للسيطره على على الماساه ونحن نتحدث الان
الاخبار العاجله ارتفاع عدد القتلى
الزلزال في سوريا وتركيا الى
23,500 قتيل او ضحيه
سيزداد بكل تاكيد هذا العدد يعني لم يتم
استخراج كل من في تحت الانقاض يعني العدد
يقطر ما بين 60 الى 100 الف قتيل
ولذلك نقول انها كانت كارثه حقيقيه
شامله
تتجاوز الحدود التركيه كارثه عالميه ما
تحتاج الحكومه يعني
الان يعني المساعدات الداخليه والخارجي
والخارجيه متوفره لا تحتاج يعني هناك فرق
منتشره يعني كما قلت اكثر من 100 الف عنصر
محترف تعمل في الساحه المساعدات
اكثر مما ربما تحتاج اليه الناس هناك بعض
الخلل في توزيع هذه المساعدات الى
المحتاجين يعني هناك عمل على توزيع الغذاء
والمياه ومواد التنظيف مهمه جدا قد تكون
هناك بعض النقص في مواد التنظيف
هناك بعض الخلل في التنسيق والتنزيع ومع
ستتم التغلب على هذه المشكله من اسطنبول
المحلل السياسي اوبتاي يلمس شكرا جزيلا لك
على هذه المشاركه
المشاهدين هذه التغطيه مستمره من قناه
العربيه بعد قليل رشا نبيل تصحبكم في ساعه
من التغطيه حول هذا الزلزال المدمر اطيب
التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته